[upbeat music]
[mellow curious music]
Are you there God?
It's me, Margaret.
[upbeat music]
I'm here to speak to you today
about your changing bodies.
[WOMAN]
The blood is released
through the vagina.
[upbeat music]
[MARGARET]
Please, just do this
one thing for me.
[upbeat music]
Just let me be normal and
regular like everybody else.
Just please, please, please,
please, please, please, please.
♪ What I feel, I can't say ♪
I've decided I want you
to join my secret club.
[hairspray hissing]
Ow.
[hair crackling]
If you wanna be in the
club, then you have to wear--
A bra.
Oh, do you think you need one?
Are you okay?
You can tell me the truth.
- [man screams]
- Fine.
Good. Yes.
We have the Campus Improvement
Committee, any volunteers?
Social Committee.
[bell pings]
Fundraising Committee.
And how are you?
I read that when you don't
have any loved ones around
your life expectancy
drops drastically.
But you know
I've had a good run.
[woman sighs]
[upbeat music]
♪ Tell me who am I ♪
It's tiring, trying so hard
all the time, doesn't it?
♪ By my side ♪
[JANIE]
I don't know
if I wanna do this.
It's just that we're ready.
Please God,
let it be a lady.
[metal creaking]
[upbeat music]
Do you think any of us will
look like that when we're 19?
We must. We must.
We must increase our bust.
[upbeat music]